church bells ringing that's because it's
wedding season when I moved to Germany
and eventually got married here I
discovered a few German wedding customs
that are fun unusual and even silly
[Music]
weddings in Germany often starred long
before the wedding of course
bachelor and bachelorette parties are
big here but many couples also invite
friends over at the night before the
wedding to break porcelain yep you heard
that right
they have a party called a poser on and
throw cups and slaves and even toilets
that's because shards of porcelain are
thought to bring lack in Germany many
Germans get married not just once but
twice
I mean to the same person that's because
a church wedding isn't recognized by the
state so all couples have to get married
first at the civil registry office those
who want to then organize a church
wedding which sometimes takes place many
months later
many brides in Germany don't wear big
elaborate dresses with long trains and
those who do opt for a veil tend to
choose ones that go down to their
fingertips and not the floor so what's
the most bridal gowns look like let's
visit a bridal store to find out visit
our supership outside house yeah tip is
a proud Clyde can I fly sigan if this is
success model it's Pizza classic
alia on is the tent with space an
incline of a serum it's usually the
groom's job in Germany to pick up his
bride's bouquet but are there any other
customs when it comes to wedding
bouquets here's what a wedding florist
has to say Vicky could appear gifted by
my heart cause I think she's a soldier
stay avoiding Gambian pouched as Alfonso
a virus I am NOT a scientist often China
looks bring it as water I'm a malevolent
product or service on the sea it's not
justice Atlas was email the limousines
inclines descended for abided their
desire to viruses in the same costume
this would enter soon as them and
understand disconsolate Abyad
German wedding parties don't usually
include bridesmaids and groomsmen
instead the bride and groom each choose
a witness who is usually a sister a
brother or a best friend so what are the
witnesses expected to do during the
wedding
we as someone who's been asked to be a
witness at an upcoming wedding in
Germany basically what is Vienna
Palatine either doesn't do things the
college arena didn't least highlight it
and yeah the stipulation type of channel
santervas line fashion to show surviving
winter shyam onto the fall try to design
know after the wedding ceremony all the
guests receive white ribbons to tie to
their cars for the drive to the
reception that way everyone knows who's
part of the wedding besides the fact
that all the cars on their way to the
reception also honk their horns as
loudly as I said German Brides should
watch out once they get to the reception
because they might just get kidnapped
that's right sometimes friends of the
couple steal the bride quietly and take
her to a nearby pub when the groom
notices she's missing he hasn't go out
looking for her but once he finds her he
can't just take her back to the party Oh
No
first yes to fulfill a task like paying
for the drinks at the pub or singing a
song sometimes in Germany the wedding
gig isn't cut right after dinner but at
the stroke of midnight of course it's
the first joint task the bride and groom
has a complete as a married couple and
how they do it can mean something later
on down the road we found out more from
a wedding cake maker Thomas's vistas via
the hospice total engagement with a
local analysis in Georgian palsu - Papa
of acacia combed and eaten Susanna fire
trying to the mind on the Hawks head
start on the bottom test method aborted
and if China hand of Johannes vodka mine
Gandhi Tata Angus Newton edited as
Esther stuck in the mud - hide the fetus
at Susie's on Western so Abajo to target
site also feel emergency at meteora
ohmmeter Nast
skunks individual Arabic lavender if
you're single and checking out that
good-looking guy or girl be sure to look
for the right hand literally I mean
married people here intend to wear their
wedding rings on their right hands
usually the Rings are fairly simple and
don't involve huge diamonds so what do
typical German wedding bands look like
we went to a jeweler to find out busy
interfering out there to be sure
clouding in deutschland is the classic
ax in inertia Jason Foreman intercept is
inviting on previous in an ultra chic
little Club ice-cold Gale cold or ROC
gold odor of cotton and their
candleholders et / / English after my
English answer in that way and Stine
besides odor of our nutrition washtech
thing a little finished consistent if
you're planning and tying the knot
sometime soon you now have some German
traditions you might want to incorporate
in your own wedding and also love to
hear about wedding traditions in your
country but we've a comment and tell me
about them thanks for watching meet the
Germans and see you next time
[Music]
you